33 Jahre vereint aber wie viel Einheit
haben wir erreicht wie viele fühlen sich
nicht angenommen nicht angekommen das
war für mich keine wiederverinigung
sondern eine feindliche Übernahme ganz
ganz viele meiner Freunde zahlen ihre
Miete nicht an ostdeutsche
HausbesitzerInnen sondern an
westdeutsche gängige Praxis der
Großbanken in Deutschland ist ganz klar
dass der Osten immer noch
risikogebietes Heimatverlust
Fremdheitsgefühle und Abwertungen mir
kommt das alles bekannt vor richtig
vieles von dem was ostdeutsche berichten
ähnelt den Erfahrungen von Migranten
Menschen deren Eltern eingewandert sind
das heißt nicht ich bin Bürger zweiter
Klasse es ist ich werde zum Bürger
zweiter Klasse gemacht ich habe mich
eine Zeit lang auch Bürger dritter
Klasse gefühlt die sehen nicht wie viel
wir gastarbeit dazu beitragen dass
Deutschland heute das ist was es ist
wenig Respekt nicht die gleichen Chancen
haben Ostdeutsche und Migranten das etwa
gemeinsam dazu spreche ich mit Menschen
die lange in der Bundesrepublik leben
und doch mit diesem Land
hadern und ich treffe eine Frau die uns
das erste Fernsehinterview seit ihrem
Ausscheiden aus dem Amt
gibt viele Jahre habe ich immer ein ganz
bestimmtes Gefühl gehabt wenn ich durch
das Brandenburger Tor gegangen bin blieb
immer etwas bes
[Musik]
Angela Merkel die wir schaffen das
Kanzlerin die ihre ostdeutsche Identität
erst sehr spät zum Thema machte das
Gespräch mit ihr auch unerwartet
persönlich es war wie wie so ein kleiner
Schlag in den magengruppe muss ich ganz
ehrlich
[Musik]
sagen
Ende der 90er Jahre bin ich in den Osten
gegangen ich habe dort mehrere Jahre bei
einem Radiosender gearbeitet und was ich
wieo ein roter Faden durchzog war bei
vielen Menschen und Kollegen das Gefühl
nicht wirklich angekommen zu sein im
wiederereinigten Deutschland ein Gefühl
dass viele Menschen mit
Zuwanderungsgeschichte so wie ich sehr
gut kennen und ich möchte in
persönlichen Gesprächen heraus finden
gibt's dieses Gefühl 33 Jahre nach der
Wiedervereinigung und Jahrzehnte nachdem
die ersten Gastarbeiter nach Deutschland
gekommen sind immer
noch und auch auf die Fakten will ich
schauen wie groß sind die Unterschiede
z.B bei Lohn Erbe oder
Besitz ich starte in Ostdeutschland wo
es zwar ein zunehmend starkes
Selbstbewusstsein gibt aber offenbar
fühlen sich immer noch viele
zurückgesetzt und das spiegelt sich auch
wieder in einer repräsentativen Umfrage
der Forschungsgruppe
Wahlen wir wollten wissen ist der
Vorwurf berechtigt dass sich ostdeutsche
als Bürger zweiter Klasse
fühlen und tatsächlich 50% der Befragten
ostdeutschen Stimmen dieser Aussage auch
heute noch zu und dieser Wert hat in den
letzten Jahren nicht etwa abgenommen
sondern er bleibt
stabil ich bin unterwegs und frage nach
woher kommt dieses Gefühl der
Benachteiligung ja wir kämpfen also mehr
auch finanziell als wie die
westdeutschenchen auf jeden Fall das ist
der finanzielle Unterschied und deswegen
fühlen sich die Bürger alle zweiter
Klasse wahrscheinlich z.B er immer
gelebt worden und es müss wir selber
leben und da gibt eben auch welche die
das gar nicht können die dann nicht
damit zurecht
kommen natürlich ist es für viele dann
auch schwierig weil sie gebrochene
Karrieren haben Sie vielleicht
arbeitslos waren lange Zeit in den 90er
Jahren und demsprechend auch häufig dann
wirtschaftlich nicht so gut gestellt
sind wie die Leute die vielleicht am
besten durchgängig gearbeitet haben und
durchgängig Karriere machen knen bin
schon noch so bisschen mit diesem Ossi
Wessi und vorurteilsding aufgewachsen
und habe auch das Gefühl gerade in
meiner heimatreion also im fruchtland
das flamt wieder ein bisschen auf aber
das ist halt trotzdem nicht dieses
zweite Klasse bedeutet das ist einfach
nur was anderes Biss bisschen andere
Identität eine andere Identität eine aus
der auch Kraft geschöpft wird scheint
bei jungen Ostdeutschen weit verbreit
auf einer Konferenz in Kemnitz treffe
ich die Modedesignerin Eva HTZ ihre
Initiative lokaltextil will den
Niedergang der ostdeutschen
Textilindustrie Bremsen in der zu DDR
Zeiten hundttausende Nähten webten und
strickten also das ist aus unserem
Partnerbetrieb wir machen
textilwirtschaftsrettung eentlich auch
und das ist die leinweberei Hoffmann in
der Lausitz die haben wir letztes Jahr
schützt sozusagen da sind jetzt 17
Arbeitsplätze erhalten und die weben
weiter wie Textilindustrie langsam
verschwindet das kenne ich aus meiner
Heimatstadt rine wo ich als Jugendlicher
gejobt habe dort sind sehr viele
Arbeitsplätze über einen Zeitraum von
Jahrzehnten verschwunden in der
ehemaligen DDR ist es durch die Wende
innerhalb weniger Jahre
passiert ist es etwas was passiert wurde
vielleicht sogar ausgenutzt wurde vom
Westen weil die gesagt haben wir zeigen
den jetzt mal wie es läuft wir sehen das
ja wer wer hat die wer hat den Hut auf
in den Firmen auch die ich kenne ne das
sind ganz oft Menschen die aus
badenwürttenberg kurz nach der wen hier
hergekommen sind es ist eben einfach so
dass die Menschen die hier in in Firmen
gearbeitet haben die staatlich
organisiert waren den wurde oft das
Selbstbewusstsein genommen in dem Moment
wo sie vielleicht hätten sagen können
ich ma es jetzt einfach da wurde nicht
gesagt e komm ich nehme Dich an die Hand
ich zeig dir wie Wirtschaft hier geht
nee es wurde gesagt ist ineffizient mach
die Maschinen weg
komm mehr als 300.000 Menschen arbeiten
1989 in DDR Textilbetrieben D Jahre
später sind es weniger als 50 000 im
Industriemuseum zeigt eine Tafel wie
massiv der Stellenabbau in den Fabriken
war wir sehen ja hier auf dem Plakat
eigentlich den Horror in Zahlen
abgedruckt was hat das dann für die
Beschäftigten für die Frauen vielfach
bedeutet das bedeutet Trauma tiefe
Trauer also das ist natürlich irgendwie
da muss muss man erstmal bewältigt
kriegen und glaube ich nicht nur in der
Industrie es ist ja auf ganz ganz vielen
Ebenen passiert die Arbeitsplatzverluste
und war ja eine Massenarbeitslosigkeit
ne und es ist natürlich nicht das
heißversprechen blühende Landschaft wenn
ich dann schlagartig irgendwie ohne das
bin was ich mal getan
habe wir fahren zum webereimuseum in
Braunsdorf eine halbe Stunde von kemnz
ist das entfernt ostgeschichte auf 33
Jahre nach der Wende
[Musik]
lebendig braucht man schon europx oder
so ne krass
laut Cornelia Hilsberg leitet das Museum
zur Wende arbeitete sie selbst an diesen
Maschinen ich war gerade fertig mit
meiner Ausbildung zum textilfacharbeiter
mit Abitur und ich wollte
Textilmaschinenbau studieren in Kemnitz
und mit einem Mal war die hinfällig also
ich stand nach D Jahren komplett vor
nichts und habe mir gesagt ja wer bin
ich was habe ich bis jetzt
gemacht dass im Osten Millionen
innerhalb kurzer Zeit umschulen einen
neuen Beruf erlernen mussten das machen
sich im Westen vermutlich nur wenige
bewusst ich habe nicht das Gefühl dass
das anerkannt wird ja es gibt ja eher
den Begriff des jammerossis vielleicht
eher so nach dem Motto habt euch nicht
so ich denke aber dass dieser aubliche
Schnitt dieser Bruch den wir erlebt
haben und dass es eben nicht anerkannt
wurde dass das immer noch nachwirkt und
immer noch diese Kluft zwischen West und
Ost ja sich dar auf zurück führen
lässt nicht die DDR als Unrechtsstaat
verteidigen die Frauen sondern das was
die Menschen geleistet
haben in ihrem Atelier in Leipzig bringt
Eva hwitz neues Leben in die Mode des
Ostens und sie kritisiert dass die
Ungerechtigkeiten der Wende bis heute
anhalten ganz ganz viele meiner
Freundinnen und Freunde zahlen ihre
Miete nicht an ostdeutsche
HausbesitzerInnen sondern an
westdeutsche HausbesitzerInnen es ist
aber einfach auch der Tatsache
geschuldet dass wir aus einer Geschichte
kommen in der 40 Jahre lang Menschen
Kapital erarbeiten konnten in dem
kapitalistischen Wirtschaftssystem und
in der ehemaligen
DDR die komplette
Privatwirtschaft verstaatlicht wurde und
das heißt es sind 40 Jahre die keen
Privatkapital erwirtschaftet werden
konnten und damit haben wir 40 Jahre
weniger Kapital was vererbt werden
kann und dieser Unterschied beim Erben
zwischen Ost und West der ist gewaltig
[Musik]
während im Saarland durchschnittlich 70
000 in Hamburg sogar
250 000 € an die nächste Generation
weitergegeben werden sind es im Osten
nur 10 bis 20 000
[Musik]
€ weniger Erben quasi bei Null Anfang
und mehr leisten als andere das kennt
nicht nur aus deutsche sondern auch
zugewanderte und ihre
Kinder meine Eltern gehören dazu auch
sie kamen vor Jahrzehnten leisteten
ihren Beitrag zum Aufbau der deutschen
Wirtschaft und sie
blieben so wie die Eltern von hyia
[Musik]
öst
morgenau
freut mich hallo ich bin herzlich
willkommen ja oder günin wie man
sagt hia Ö führt die Kölner Konditorei
in zweiter Generation übernommen hat sie
das Geschäft von ihrem Vater Hassan der
vor über 50 Jahren als Textilarbeiter
nach Deutschland kam weil das Gehalt für
eine neunköpfige Familie nicht reichte
baute hylias Vater aus dem Nichts eine
Konditorei
auf seine Spezialität frittierte
hefekringel ich kann mich daran erinnern
dass ich immer um 5 Uhr morgens
aufstehen musste eigentlich wir alle wir
mussten dann backen während der
Schulzeit oder ja während der Schulzeit
ja weil mein Vater konnte sich damals
also in den Anfangsjahren mit der
Selbständigkeit konnte der sich ja kein
Personal leisten ja und dann mussten wir
morgens um 5 5:30 Uhr aufstehen dann
mussten wir wirklich backen bis 7 Uhr
auch dieses Spritzgebäck ist ja und dann
zur Schule und das ist ja so richtiges
fettgebck gewesen was so im frittierten
Öl frittiert wurde und dann haben wir
auch entsprechend immer nach Öl
geschunken quasi und dann gingen wir zur
Schule dann hieß ja immer ja
Kinderarbeit Kinderarbeit dürft ihr
nicht sagen ihr dürft nicht sagen dass
ihr arbeitet ne ja dann hieß warum
riecht die denn so extrem nach Öl und
das was wir dann gesagt haben ja meine
Mama hat gestern Pommes gemacht meine
Mama hat gestern Pommes gemacht wie oft
habt ihr dann Pommes gegessen wirklich
sage ich ganz ehrlich also es war
wirklich hart kannst du uns zeigen wie
du oder wie ihr hier arbeitet ja klar
gerne
wie das hier riecht schon
toll so zack okay jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt oh Gott ich finde es gar nicht
so
einfach wenn aus der Luft macht ist die
Gleichmäßigkeit ja alles klar okay es
soll regnen sieht schon besser aus noch
fünf bläche dann hast du den Dreh
[Musik]
raus
da ist es ja dein backl vorin gemacht
hast will ich doch mal hier neh ich das
[Musik]
mal super back
wirklich in der Wohnung über dem
Geschäft wohnt jas Vater Hassan heute
sind auch has Brüder und NEB zu Besuch
hallo
Pap
Hall Hall hallo Bruder Bruder Nummer 2
Bruder Nummer 6 oh got ich B die Nummer
s hauptsache ihr habt den
Überblick wir als Gastarbeiter haben
kein Kredit GEK also nicht wir ke keine
Bank
eine waren sie bei der Bank haben sie
mal gefragt ich habe gefragt zweimal
hier in Stad sparkast
kann man nichts geben her her her wo
willst du bezahlen wie wie willst du
bezahlen kein waren sie waren nicht
kreditwürdig für die Bank keine keine
aber hya hat von der Bank dann doch
Kredit bekommen als sie alles größer
gemacht hat und neu die Leute die denken
dass es eine deutsche
Mädchen was bin ich denn für dich
deutsch oder
türkisch beide beide nicht
Hassan sind sie angekommen in
Deutschland auch so mit dem Gefühl ich
zufrieden ja ja der Papa ist zufrieden
er ist
irgendwie der Papa ist richtig zufrieden
damals hatten sie nicht die Zeit sich
damit auseinanderzusetzen ob die hier
angekommen sind ob die Gastarbeiter sind
oder sonst was weil die einfach so in
ihrem ich sag mal den den den Alltag zu
bewältigen oder die Familie zu ernähren
oder sich was aufzubauen und als wir
dann angefangen haben in der Schule
unseren Platz zu suchen in unserer
Ausbildung in unserer Weiterbildung
finde ich ist man viel mehr damit
konfrontiert geworden weil man sich dann
natürlich auch in Position stellen
wollte wo man quasi mitmischt noch mal
an euch dann die Frage fühlt ihr euch
manchmal als Bürger oder Bürgerin
zweiter Klasse ich persönlich ja aus dem
Grund ich habe mal eine Zeit ein Job
gesucht als deutschen Konditor hab dann
gesagt schönen guten Tag mein Name ist
her Ö ich möchte gerne als Konditor hier
arbeiten würde Ihnen gerne ein Tag
Probearbeit anbieten und weil er Name so
türkisch war Serv zözdag kam von zehn
Läden neun Absagen auf dem gleichen
Atemzug bin ich dann nach Hause gegangen
habe gesagt so das kann ich mir nicht
bieten lassen ich möchte das jetzt
wissen hab dann noch mal angerufen und
hab dann gesagt hier Stefan Schneider
ich möchte gerne bei ihn als Konditor
arbeiten als würde gerne Probearbeit
machen von zehn Stellen sieben Zusagen
ich füh mich definitiv angekommen und
ich möchte es nicht missen und ich bin
dankbar hier sein zu dürfen nicht mehr
und nicht weniger vermisst ihr das in
der deutschen Erzählung dass ihr
eigentlich auch zu Deutschland gehört
definitiv ja definitiv ja wir gehören zu
Deutschland was ich halt immer taaurig
finde ist dass man dann immer sagt man
ist die Ausnahme man ist die Ausnahme
aber es ist nicht mehr ja aber es ist
nicht mehr die Ausnahme es ist die
Mehrheit die zweite Generation die hier
lebt hat so viel geschaffen was
vielleicht viele Deutsche nicht
geschaffen haben sage ich ganz ehrlich
also sehr sehr erfolgreich wir schaffen
Arbeitsplätze wir sprechen deutsch wir
zahlen Steuern wir haben uns gut
integriert und deswegen sage ich
definitiv wie gehören
Deutschland dazu gehören das wollen
Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte ebenso
wie
ostdeutsche aber lässt man sie das
auch an der Berliner Humbold Universität
treffe ich zwei Wissenschaftler Daniel
kubijak im Osten geboren ög öwatan in
der
Türkei sie erforcht gemeinsam wie
westdeutsche auf Ostdeutsche und
Migranten schauen mit interessanten
Ergebnissen eine Frage war stimmen Sie
der Aussage zu dass die Ostdeutschen
oder die Musliminnen noch nicht im
heutigen Deutschland angekommen sind und
da war die Zustimmung für beide Gruppen
aus dem Westen heraus relativ hoch soar
um die 40%. wie wird denn über diese
beiden Gruppen geredet noch nicht im
heutigen Deutschland angekommen neigen
zu Radikalität zu Rad radikalen
politischen Position und
demokratieferne es wird den Gruppen wird
demokratieferne zugeschrieben und das
verbindet natürlich diese verschiedenen
Aspekte wo wir dann sagen können na ja
die sind demokratiefern weil die sind
radikal und deswegen sind sie auch nicht
in dem heutigen Deutschland angekommen
und sie jammern also das ist auch so
eine Erzählung die die Gruppen neigen
dazu zu jammern meine Wahrnehmung ist da
ist oft gar nicht so viel jammern
sondern da ist auch ein gewisser Stolz
darauf was man so geschafft hat zu
welchen Bedingung man das geschafft hat
und man will halt einfach die
Anerkennung haben und ich meine wir
reden halt über eine Gesellschaft jetzt
in Ostdeutschland zumindest eine
Gesellschaft die in der 85% der Menschen
1993 nicht mehr den gleichen Job hatten
wie 1990 also einfach eine gesamte
Gesellschaft die sich einmal umgedreht
wurde ihre Kollegin naika furutan hat
diese Parallelen zwischen ostdeutsch und
migrantisch vor wenigen Jahren in einem
Buch dargestellt und für fore
gesorgt die Vorurteile sind das eine
hinzu kommmen handfeste wirtschaftliche
und Unterschiede die ebenfalls beide
Gruppen
betreffen das Zentrum für integrations
und Migrationsforschung stellt diesen
Vergleich schon 2019 an in Hinblick auf
das Einkommen so gehören im Westen 19%
der Menschen zur untersten
Einkommensgruppe leben also monatlich
von weniger als 1500 € netto im Osten
sind es dagegen
27% und bei den Migranten sogar 30% die
mit so wenig Geld aus komm
[Musik]
müssen aber es gibt auch die anderen
Geschichten Unternehmer wie Ingo jung
die sich etwas aufbauen konnten vor 10
Jahren hat er bei Bitterfeld in
SachsenAnhalt den gotschesee gekauft und
entwickelt ihn zu einem
Ausflugsziel wir haben den Aquapark den
wir hinten sehen errichtet wir haben den
wegpark gebaut wir haben feinhäuser wir
haben Restaurants und der nächste
Schritt den wir jetzt vorhen wir wollen
spät im nächsten Jahr mit einem neuen
Hotel Projekt beginnen ich s wir hatten
damals Helm K unseren einheitskanzler
der damals die blüne Landschaften
versprochen hat ich muss klar sagen für
mich sind das blüende Landschaften und
insofern ärg ich mich auch manchmal wenn
der ein oder andere vielleicht mit ein
bisschen wenig demoanght und sagt Mensch
ist doch alles schlecht im
ossen zu Ostzeiten sieht es hier in
Bitterfeld noch ganz anders aus
chemiewerke und Braunkohleindustrie
verschaffen 10us Menschen
Arbeit riesiger Tagebau gräbt sich durch
die Landschaft die Stadt gilt als
dreckigste
Europas mit der Wände verlieren die
meisten auf einen Schlag ihre Arbeit
Bitterfeld geht durch ein Tal der Tränen
dann wird die stillgelegte Kohlegrube
geflutet der neue See die gotsche Macht
die Region zum Naturparadies und
Bitterfeld mausert sich zum modernen
Industriestandort wäre da nicht der
Streit um den See die stad verkauft ihn
weil sie wie viele ostdeutsche Kommunen
verschuldet ist Käufer Ingo jung ist
zwar ostdeutscher aber das Geld für den
See das kommt aus dem Westen von Merkle
einem Milliarden schweren Firmenimperium
aus Baden-Würtemberg Kaufpreis unter 3
Millionen Euro zu wenig für die Profite
die hier zu erwarten sind der
Bitterfelder Stadtrat lässt den Verkauf
derzeit überprüfen wurde hier etwa wie
schon zu treuhandzeiten ostdeutsches
gold
verschärbelt
typisch deutsches Phänomen und
kritisiert immer andere und die Frage
ist ja was
was leisten die Akteure die Kritiker und
ich sag mal das ist bei uns halt so dass
die die gerade am meisten kritisieren am
wenigsten leisten früher habe ich
geglaubt typisch deutsch mittlerweile
glaube ich es ist typisch ostdeutsch ich
glaube dass wir nach der
Wende so schon sehr neidisch und
missgünstig geworden sind das gab's im
Osten eigentlich früher
nicht die Kritik am
sekauf kommt aus allen Richtungen und
sie ist politisch Bitterfeld Wolfen
wählt einen Bürgermeister und es ist die
AFD die sich das Thema auf die Fahnen
schreibt Ende September hat sie den
ersten Wahlgang gewonnen und hofft nun
in der Stichwahl auf den nächsten
Wahlerfolg im Osten von Deutschland wir
hören uns in der Stadt um kaum jemand
will offen mit uns sprechen eine der
wenigen ist Diana Bäse mit der AFD hat
sie nichts zu tun aber zum seeverkauf
eine klare Meinung von meinem
persönlichen Empfinden ist es weit
unterwert vor allem wenn man bedenkt
dass hier im Vorfeld Millionen an
Fördergeldern reingeflossen sind auch
aus staatlicher Hand und am Ende ist es
halt für einen sehr geringen Betrag
veräußert worden und heute hat die Stadt
wenig Einfluss darauf was hier drumherum
passiert dadurch auch die Öffentlichkeit
nicht mehr im Laufe der letzten Jahre
sind so viele Jugendclubs geschlossen
worden es gibt kein Kino mehr die
Innenstadt ja stirbt aus den Menschen
die hier wohnen denen nützt jetzt
irgendwie kein Luxushotel am See die
werden das wahrscheinlich nicht
nutzen die westdeutsche merkleguppe hat
nicht nur den gotschesee gekauft sondern
mindestens vier weitere tagebauseehen im
Osten sowie Ecker Wälder und Immobilien
der Osten profitiert von den
Investitionen aber die Wirtschaftskraft
im Land die bleibt ungleich
verteilt von den 100 umsatzstärksten
Unternehmen Deutschlands hat auch
2023 über 30 Jahre nach der Wende nur
eins seinen Hauptsitz in
Ostdeutschland blühende Landschaften ja
aber geerntet wird im
Westen am attraktiven Seeufer der
gotsche entsteht gerade diese neue
Siedlung Ingo jung hat Schwierigkeiten
solche Projekte im Osten zu
finanzieren gängige Praxis der
Großbanken in Deutschland ist ganz klar
dass der Osten immer noch Risikogebiet
ist ja ich habe also verschiedene Banken
be denen wir arbeiten für die ist der
Osten Deutschland vom Rating immer noch
schlechter zu betrachten als ein
ähnlicher Standort in weldeutschland das
heißt du bist als Unternehmer vor Ort
natürlich auf Sparkassen und Volksbanken
angewiesen und wenn dann aber in deinen
Sparkassen Leute sitzen die nach der wen
rüber gespült wurden die sich nicht
wirklich mit der Region identifizieren
und die machen es den Unternehmern vor
Ort natürlich nicht
einfacher zwar gleichen sich Renten und
Löhne langsam an aber viele
Ungleichheiten
bleiben der ostdeutsche fühlt sich allzu
oft nicht wirklich verstanden weil
wenige ostdeutsche in
Führungsverantwortung sind in dem Land
ja wir haben ganz wenige ostdeutsche in
der Bundesregierung wenige echte
ostdeutsche in den in der
Landesregierung in den Ämtern in den
Behörden in
Führungspositionen und dadurch kommt
glaube ich auch bis
der Gedanke dass man da hinten
ansteht die vielen Millionen
ostdeutschen und auch die Menschen mit
Zuwanderungsgeschichte in Deutschland
sind nur wenig in den Eliten vertreten
ostdeutsche machen 19% der Bevölkerung
aus besetzen im Jahr 2019 aber nur 10%
der deutschen
Führungspositionen Migranten Stellen
sogar 26% der Menschen haben aber nur %
der Elite
Jobs eine aus deutsche hat es in die
Elite geschafft das ganz Ostdeutschland
ihr deswegen aber stolz zu Füßen lag das
sollte
ausbleiben
hallo guten Tag hallo da sind Sie ja
schon gleich Frau Merkel guten Tag hallo
schön dass wir reinkommen dürfen hier
hier
istü ja das ist also ihr Büro ja wie
viel Zeit verbringen Sie hier na ja
wenn ich da bin und ich bin auch häufig
im Büro
dann verbringe ich
8 ne Stunden am Tag hier im Juni 2015
Angela Merkel gibt mir das erste TV
Interview seit Ende ihrer Kanzlerschaft
sie will nicht über Tagespolitik
sprechen ich möchte von ihr wissen warum
sie als erste ostdeutsche im Amt ihre
Identität so selten betonte und wie sie
inzwischen auf die Vielfalt dieses
Landes blickt
sehr schön ja das ist ja ein Zimmer mit
Geschichte denn hier oben hat auch
Margot tonener gesessen die DDR
volksbildungsministerin und als Kinder
sind mein Bruder und ich hier unten
immer vorbeigegangen an dem Haus und
haben das Propagandamaterial des
volksbildungsministeriums der DDR
studiert oh Gott und dass ich hier mal
Land dann hat Helmut Kohl hier gesessen
auch als Altkanzler und ja jetzt hab ich
das Büro und füh mich hier sehr
[Musik]
wohl da ist
es ja und wenn man sich noch erinnert
wie trostlos das alles
aussah können sie sich denn noch daran
erinnern als sie zum ersten Mal durch
das Brandenburger Tor gegangen sind also
es ist ja nicht gleich am 9 November
geöffnet worden wie die Rest der Mauer
sondern erst kurz vor
Weihnachten und ich war nicht dabei als
die Öffnung war ich habe in der
schönhause Allee gewohnt da war ich dort
weiß noch wie beim Bäcker im Radio das
übertragen wurde dass es jetzt geöffnet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist bin dann sicherlich am 23 also ein
Tag später durch viele Jahre habe ich
immer ein ganz bestimmtes Gefühl gehabt
wenn ich durch das Brandenburger Tor
gegangen bin also das hat sich erst nach
bestimmt 15 Jahren normalisiert es blieb
immer etwas Besonderes und jetzt sind
zack 33 bzw 34 Jahre um
ja Frau Merkel deutsche Einheit
Ostdeutschland Perspektive von
zuwandergenation 1 2 3 das ist das Thema
jetzt ist das hier ihr allererstes TV
Interview seit amendsausscheiden warum
haben Sie sich für dieses Thema
entschieden ja das Thema als solches
interessiert mich und dann ist ja auch
eine meiner letzten reden die Rede zum
Tag der Deutschen Einheit gewesen in
Halle
2021 jetzt fand ich eigentlich den
Bezug recht interessant und deshalb habe
ich mich zu dem ersten Interview wieder
entschieden das war ja im letzten Jahr
ihrer Kanzlerschaft als sie diese Rede
gehalten haben und dabei haben sie etwas
erwähnt dass ich so ähnlich häufig
gehört habe in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen auf meiner drehreise sie haben
davon gesprochen
dass ihre DDR Vergangenheit als Ballast
bezeichnet wurde ich möchte Ihnen ein
Beispiel aus meinem Leben erzählen in
einem Ende letzten Jahres von der Konrad
Adenauer Stiftung herausgegebenen Buch
heißt es in einem der dort
veröffentlichten Aufsätze über mich ich
zitiere sie die als 35-Jährige mit dem
Ballast ihrer DDR Biografie in den
wendetagen zur CDU kam konnte natürlich
kein von der piee auf spezialisiertes
CDU Gewächs altbundesrepublikanischer
Prägung sein Zitat Ende die DDR
Biografie also eine persönliche
Lebensgeschichte von in meinem Fall 35
Jahren einem Staat der Diktatur und
Repression
Ballast was haben sie dabei empfunden
als sie das zum ersten Mal gelesen haben
weil es war ja ein Artikel in dem das
veröffentlicht wurde ja es war wie so
eine kleine wie so ein kleiner Schlag in
die Magengrube muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe das war eine Darstellung
meiner Zeit als Parteivorsitzende als
CDU Vorsitzende und ich habe irgendwie
erst erst gar nicht richtig glauben
können und dann habe ich noch mal
gelesen aber es war Ballast und da habe
ich
natürlich irgendwo mich ja also entkernt
gefühlt weil alles was mich ausmacht
natürlich die Biografie das Aufwachsen
in der DDR war und man kann ja nicht von
einem Menschen irgendetwas abtrennen und
so dann war ich einfach Buff da muss man
erstmal drauf kommen und das haben sie
dann artikuliert in dieser Rede und
haben hundertprozentig einen Nerv
getroffen bei vielen Millionen in
Ostdeutschland und ich habe mich gefragt
warum haben sie das erst so spät
formuliert diese Worte die sehr
eindeutig waren was hat Sie davon
abgehalten das vorher zu machen also
interessanterweise ist ja der Artikel
mir erst unter die Augen gekommen als
meine Parteivorsitz Karriere schon
beendet war aber jetzt davon abgesehen
ich hätte so eine persönliche Bemerkung
in meiner Amtszeit wenn es jetzt nicht
zum Ende hingegangen wäre wahrscheinlich
nicht gemacht weil ich mich immer als
Kanzlerin aller deutschen verstanden
habe vielleicht auch manchmal nicht so
getraut habe aus der
ddrzeit frank und frei dauernd zu
sprechen weil das wieder auch so eine
Art Stigmatisierung geworden wäre jetzt
kommt sie wieder mit ihrem
Ostdeutschland oder so son
ich habe das dann viel mit mir selber
ausgemacht oder im Wahlkreis darüber
gesprochen aber eben nicht als
Bundeskanzlerin ist wie eine Monstranz
vor mir hergetragen
aber ich war dann
doch auch erstaunt wie viele Leute dann
das auch als etwas verstanden haben was
sie auch angeht und insofern plädiere
ich doch dafür das Gespräch darüber auch
immer wieder zu führen das habe ich
nämlich auch gedacht sie hätten ja eine
Brücke schlagen könnt zu denen die das
so empfunden haben nach der Wende gab es
viele Enttäuschung eben auch durch
das was sie gerade beschrieben haben
dass man sozusagen abgewertet wurde die
die Biografie quasi ausgelöscht fand
dann nicht mehr statt dann hätten sie
doch viele Millionen früher mitnehmen
können oder na ja es ist ja nicht so
dass ich nie darüber gesprochen habe
also ich habe immer auch darüber geredet
dass es einen Unterschied gibt zwischen
dem Staat DDR des Überwindung wir
natürlich alle begeistert
gefeiert haben und einem persönlichen
Leben das ja in jedem Land mehr ist als
nur die staatliche Struktur Gott sei
Dank und auch die DDR hat es trotz aller
Versuche Jugendliche immer wieder zu
beeinflussen natürlich nicht geschafft
die Familie zu ersetzen und man hatte
Freunde man hat gefeiert wir sind mit
den Eltern in Urlaub gefahren das waren
ja alles
Erlebnisse und dann gibt es noch die
prägenden Erlebnisse durch den ST ich
meine die Anwesenheit von Freiheit formt
Menschen aber die Abwesenheit von
Freiheit formt sie ja auch und da
erlernt man auch wichtige Dinge darüber
hatte ich schon gesprochen aber ehrlich
gesagt mir wäre auch gar nicht in Kopf
gekommen ich hätte das ja selber nicht
niederschreiben können dass jemand
schreibt die Biografie in der DDR war
Ballast sie waren die Kanzlerin aller
deutschen m aber in meiner Wahrnehmung
haben sie im Osten zumindest in den
letzten Jahren sehr viel an an Missmut
[Musik]
abbekommen womit erklären Sie sich das
na ja es gab einen Teil der Menschen die
sehr wütend auf mich waren das hat sich
hat begonnen während der Zeit als der
Euro in Schwierigkeiten kam aber dann
als auch sehr viele Flüchtlinge zu uns
kam da hat sich die Lage polarisiert
aber ich habe auch immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen würde das hier auch gerne
noch mal tun dass ich ja immer meinen
Wahlkreis gewonnen habe also es ist ja
nicht so dass die Mehrzahl der Menschen
in den neuen Bundesländern mich
angeschrienen hätte sondern es gab einen
Teil und eine sehr radikale und auch
laute und
intolerante Gruppe aber sehr sehr viele
Menschen haben es natürlich ganz anders
gesehen und es ist auch etwas
bekümmerliches fast dass sozusagen der
laut e den letzten Eindruck hinterlässt
und viele Menschen die leise und auch
sich dagegen wehren gegen diese
Intoleranz die kommen viel weniger zu
Wort und das ist auch nicht in Ordnung
auf meiner drehreise sind mir in
Ostdeutschland häufig Menschen begegnet
ganz normale Lehrer Ingenieure und so
weiter die Verständnis dafür geäußert
haben dass die Menschen im Osten
verstärkt AFD wählen verstehen sie das
nein also ich ich möchte dafür kein
Verständnis äußern weil ich glaube ich
verstehe dass man über manches verärgert
ist dass man nicht alles gut findet
m aber ich bin nicht bereit zu
akzeptieren dass man deshalb Ideen und
gedankenut unterstützt was für mich
nichts mit dem was ich als Toleranz oder
was im Rahmen meiner Toleranz akzeptabel
ist und wenn man sich sozusagen auf
Kosten anderer Menschen auch anders
aussehender Menschen von Menschen mit
anderer Biografie profiliert dann ist
das nichts wofür ich Verständnis habe da
würde ich immer dagegen argumentieren
und würde sagen man kann in dieser
demokratischen Gesellschaft wirklich
auch anders seine Kritik und sein Ärger
zum Ausdruck bringen
über Vielfalt und Zusammenhalt spreche
ich später noch mit
ihr ja was mich wirklich überrascht hat
ist dass Angela Merkel sich ja verlz
gezeigt hat also dass sie eine
Unsicherheit eingestanden hat sie hat
gesagt dass sie sich nicht getraut hat
ihre ostdeutsche Identität während ihrer
Kanzlerschaft stärker zu betonen sie war
16 Jahre Kanzlerin und hat das also
quasi erst ganz zum Schluss ihrer
Kanzlerschaft gemacht also das hat mich
wirklich sehr
überrascht dieser Frust im Osten der
auch exkanzlerin Merkel immer stärker
entgegenschlug den will ich besser
verstehen und bin bei Tom Bernau am
Muldestausee in SachsenAnhalt wo er eine
kleine Fischerei und eine kleine Farm
betreibt schon der nächste Tag das ist
dann jeden morgen passiert das ja ja so
beginnt das Leben eines Fisches h gehen
mal noch das Gatter zu machen okay nicht
dass du Weihnachtsbraten davon fliegen
ja genau oder dann kommt da Herr Fuchs
hauen die ab ne ja Emily
Mensch welchen Fisch fangen Sie am
häufigsten am häufigen also mein mein
brutfisch ist der Zander Zander Zander
BCH Fischer Bernau hat sich kurz nach
der Wende selbstständig gemacht und er
bekommt im Gespräch mit seinen Kunden
mit was die Menschen hier
aufregt vorsichtig
die meine Güte was für ein riesen
vie wie so viele findet auch er das
Einwanderer heute das Leben zu leicht
gemacht werde während die Ostdeutschen
nach der Wende hat schuften mussten um
sich ihr kleines bisschen Wohlstand
aufzubauen aber das ist ein ganz heites
Thema ja da ten sich scheinbar auch
große Parteien nicht ran ja aber da muss
es mal richtig ja me jeder der hierherkt
nach Deutschland der sollte auch
arbeiten aber wenn er herkommt dann soll
er auch auch soziale Leistung bringen
für die Gemeinschaft sonst funktioniert
die Gemeinschaft irgendwann nicht mehr
das Problem ist nicht alle dürfen
arbeiten die herkommen ne das ist ja das
ist das Problem das LI aber Politik
nicht an uns viele kommen ja auch nur
her praktisch auch wenn Deutschland ist
attraktiv ja warum kommen die Leute her
muss man sich ab auch mal fragen ja ja
und gut ja andere wollen auch was dran
teil haben sollen sie auch aber da
müssen sie auch was dafür tun und das
ist viel bei vielen Leuten stößt das an
ja von der Politik sind viele Menschen
im Osten schon länger enttäuscht aber
jetzt wird dieses Gefühl besonders von
einer Partei aufgegriffen der AFD sie
profiliert sich als Stimme des
Ostens so sehen sie ja sehr fett halt
sehr schöne Fische da wissen Sie schon
da sitzt jeder Schnitt hier ja na ja l
das L ja ja aber bereitet ihn das sorgen
dass dann wenn dann die Leute zur Wahl
gehen dass sie AFD wählen und viele
damit Problem me dann hat was verkehrt
gemacht das ist n mal Demokratie ja aber
dass die Partei in großen Teilen
verfassungsfeindlich ist oder
rechtsextremistisch macht bereitet ihn
das sorgen ja manchmal sind d die Medien
auch ein bisschen weit ja ich meine wenn
sie rechtswidig ist verfassungfeinlich
ist dann wir verboten dazu haben wir
Gesetze die ist aber nicht verboten also
kann du nicht rechtsftig Verfassung fre
nicht sein ja das he h und wieder gibt's
nicht ja ist entweder es gibt's was oder
es gibt's nicht und spekulieren kann
jeder über eine
Partei die Medien sind das nächste
Reizthema besonders wir öffentlich
rechtliche auch das muss man mal
aushalten können
ach so das ist der Raum hier in dem
Moment wo ich sage ist
verfassungsheitlich als als öffentlicher
rech Sender in dem Moment nehme ich doch
Stellung ja aber so muss man das aber
sehen du sehen das viele Leute ja das
sehen die Leute im ersten Blick sehen
das so ja und dann ist noch komm dazu
wden DDR früher auch sehr viel
bevormundet das ist wird hier Osten sage
ich jetzt vielleicht mehr wahrgenommen
als in den alten Bundesländern da ist
man das mehr gewöhnt ja da habst du
meinzel Männchen schon
immer so sagen ja
Vertrauensverlust in die Arbeit von uns
öffentlich rechtlichen und der Zuspruch
zur AFD das sind Dauerthemen die AFD
wird zwar auch im Westen gewählt aber im
Osten eben ganz besonders
häufig meine Wahrnehmung ist dass wir
uns manchmal zu sehr Aufhängen an der
Frage warum ist das im Osten größer
anstatt diese Frage für gesamt
Deutschland zu stellen wir müssen uns
mit Rechtsextremismus in Ostdeutschland
beschäftigen und wir müssen uns
gleichzeitig mit Rechtsextremismus in
westdeutland beschäftigen aus der
westdeutschen Perspektive nehmen wir an
dass wir aus der Geschichte so viel
gelernt haben dass wir gemütlich sein
können und Teil dieser Gemütlichkeit ist
eben auch immer demokratietheoretische
Probleme auf andere auszulagern und
diese Gemütlichkeit haben wir nicht mehr
also diese nie wiedererzählung mit der
ich groß geworden bin ich habe sie noch
nie so sehr in Gefahr gesehen ja
ja einer der sich auch Sorgen macht ist
emilianoimite als Vertragsarbeiter kommt
der 1986 aus mosambikque in die DDR und
lebt heute in
[Musik]
Dresden ich habe mich eine zeitenlang
auch Bürger dritte Klasse gefühlt ja ich
dachte dass erste zweite Klasse wie die
ostdeutchen selber aber dann habe ich
dann gemerkt sie wollen mich auch nicht
dabei haben die Vertragsarbeiter Leben
zu ddrzeiten in isolierten Wohnheim nach
der Wende sind rassistische Übergriffe
an der
Tagesordnung natürlich hatten wir nach
der Wende Angst also das war nicht zu zu
unterdrücken es war Gang und Gebe dass
wir gesag immer gesagt haben ab 18 Uhr
darf man überhaupt nicht mehr alleine
auf die Straße
gehen ich weiß dass es ist schwierig ist
eine Gesellschaft die zum Teil so in
sich eingesperrt war wie der gewesen ist
plötzlich jetzt äh Z eine äh
einwanderungs Gesellschaft werden soll
ich will auch mein Leben nicht dafür
offen im ewig Opfer zu sein sondern ich
möchte vollwertiger Mitglied dieser
Gesellschaft gesehen werden und dafür
leiste ich auch eine
Menge der gelernte Krankenpfleger baut
seit der Wende mehrere Vereine für
Migranten
auf und er ist stolzer familienvahter du
hast deine bröchen nicht gegessen ad
stimmt das möchte nicht das möchtest du
nicht das nicht lecker genug ne willst
du dann dort arbeiten wie die Mama nein
nein okay verstehe
ich der Verein von Emiliano schimite
schaut jetzt besorgt aufs nächste Jahr
wenn die Sachsen einen neuen Landtag
wählen ich kommen raau Zeiten ihr wisst
wir haben jetzt 2024 Wahlen das heißt
also politische beweg Bewegungen wir
wissen nicht was da kommt und dieses
Gedankengut der AFD ist in mitittel
Gesellschaft
angekommen und auch deswegen kandidiert
er selbst für ein politisches Amt will
für die SPD in den dresner
Stadtrat als er es vor vier Jahren mit
dem Landtag versuchte wurde er nicht
gewählt Sachsen ist noch nicht bereit in
vielen Bereiche also wir haben nur nicht
nur kein einziges Stadtrat jetzt
zumindest in diesem Stadtrat geschweige
Land Landtag gibt glaube ich eine Person
mit
Migrationshintergrund und nicht nur in
Sachsen sind Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund in der Politik
kaum vertreten während sie in
Deutschland fast 29% der Bevölkerung
ausmachen stellen sie nur 11% der
Abgeordneten im Bundestag in den
Landtagen haben sogar nur 7% der
Abgeordneten migrantische
Wurzeln wenn ich so sehe wie die
Konkurrenz ist bei der Wahlliste mit der
Aufstellung der Wahlliste wahnsinn das
ist sehr sehr hart und für Menschen
mitationsografie besonderes hart weil
wir müssen zweimal so gut sein man muss
sich ausdrücken können man muss genau
auf de Punkt kommen man muss Menschen
programmatisch überzeugen also das ist
wahnsinnig
aufwendig sich immer wieder beweisen zu
müssen das höre ich auf meiner Reise
nicht zum ersten Mal wofür Emiliano
schimite kämpft er will dass Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund ein Teil der
deutschen erzählung werden und ja auch
dass Sie sich sicher fühlen können
natürlich die entwiung macht mir Sorgen
aber jetzt nicht mehr nur weil Migranten
angegriffen werden
sondern mir macht das Sorge dass die
Demokratie jetzt in großer Gefahr ist
dass Demokratie jetzt wirklich an so ein
Tiefpunkt angekommen ist wo wir sehr
aufpassen
müssen ich bin noch einmal in der
kstraße in Köln denn Hass und Gewalt
gegen
gibt es nicht nur im Osten sondern auch
im Westen im Sommer 2004 explodiert hier
eine Nagelbombe verletzt über 20
Menschen jetzt fast 20 Jahre später ist
die Bedrohung von rechts immer noch
hyliia darkks Alltag vor kurzem erhält
sie diesen Drohbrief also das war einmal
das hier also wir sind viele in
Köln ach so ganz eigentlich je nach dem
anderen Schweinekopf da oben so und dann
was ich dann krass fand war das hier
Mehl brennt gut der hat sich wirklich
die Mühe gemacht da noch ein Streichholz
hinzukleben ne also auch damals nach dem
Anschlag wo wir dann auch oft in den
Medien waren habe ich auch eine Menge
drobriefe erhalten und kriegst du dann
Angst wenn du s also im ersten ich sag
mal so damals also hatte ich keine Angst
mittlerweile bin ich ja selber Mutter
von zwei Kindern wo man sich dann
manchmal schon so Gedanken macht so man
hat jetzt Kinder aber dann habe ich mir
wiederum gedacht ich so nee das mache
ich nicht das ist genau das was Sie
erreichen wollen von sowas dass ich mich
nicht einschüch wir leben einem
Land hier herrcht Meinungsfreiheit also
werde ich das auch weiterhin
machen hia Ö ist mit ihrer
rassismuserfahrung nicht alleine mehr
als jeder Fünfte in Deutschland
berichtet von Abwertung aufgrund von
Hautfarbe oder
Herkunft manchmal sogar durch den Staat
selbst hatte ich mal zwei deutsche
Bewerber ein der aus Bayern kommt der
dann als Konditor bei uns arbeiten
wollte dann ist t zum Arbeitsamt
gegangen hat den halt die Meldung
gemacht dass er gesagt hat ja ich möchte
in der konditur özag in der käfstraße
probarbeiten gehen ja und die Antwort
die der bekommen hat sind Sie sicher
dass Sie in der kolbstraße in eine
türkische Konditorei gehen wollen und da
Probearbeit also sie müssen das nicht
machen man erwartet dass man sich
integriert ne und dann macht man das
alles so wie es sich eigentlich gehört
und wenn dann also die Behörden also die
Behörden also das muss man sich erm sagt
geh da nicht hin also was soll ich denn
da bitte noch erwarten s weit sind wir
schon ist krass Jia wenn du all das
erzählst auch mit den Erfahrungen die Du
da mit den Behörden machst was ziehst du
daraus für Schlüsse dass wir eigentlich
immer noch nicht hier angekommen sind
oder dass man uns eigentlich immer noch
nicht dazu zäht also man redet immer von
man muss sich integrieren man muss sich
integrieren aber ich denke man will
nicht dass sie sich
integrieren ich kann sie gut
verstehen so sehr man sich anstrengt so
kommt man vom
Fleck ich bin als Sohn türkischer Eltern
geboren wurde
1989 vi Wochen vor morfall als Deutscher
eingebürgert ich weiß dass ich Glück
hatte und inzwischen privilegiert lebe
aber vor Rassismus schützt auch kein
deutscher Pass wenn dann habe ich ihn
häufiger im Osten erlebt und warum das
so ist diese Frage nehme ich mit zur
ehemaligen Bundeskanzlerin
ich bin eine Person mit
Migrationshintergrund und ich habe die
Erfahrung gemacht dass ich im Osten
häufiger mit Rassismus konfrontiert
werde und ich frag mich woran das liegt
ja es ist bedauerlich
[Musik]
und auch wie gesagt erstmal nicht zu
akzeptieren aber es wenn Sie das
persönlich so berichten dass das bei
Ihnen so ist dann dann muss man es
vielleicht damit erklären dass es nicht
die Vielfalt an Biografien
öffentlich gab es wir hatten ja auch
viele
vietnamesische Vertragsarbeiter
angolanische
Vertragsarbeiter aber die wurden ja
geradezu weggesperrt aus dem
öffentlichen Leben die durften nicht
reisen mit oder nur unter bestimmten
Bedingungen wohnten in abgeschotteten
Wohnheimen und ähnlichem und es ist
vielleicht auch so dass die Menschen die
die Veränderung erlebt haben also auus
der DDR dann in die deutsche Einheit
hineingegangen sind und das ja im gro in
großer Menge begrüßt haben die haben
natürlich sehr viel Umbrüche mitbekommen
und ich weiß noch als meiner Zeit Anfang
der 90er Jahre als ich jugendministerin
war dass es fast so ein bisschen ein
Wettbewerb auch gab wenn ich mit
türkischstämmigen Jugendlichen
gesprochen habe dann haben sie gesagt
jetzt sind wir eine Klasse
runtergerutscht die besten sind
natürlich die Westdeutschen Jugendlichen
dann kommt der Ossi dran das habe ich
auch so ähnlich dann und dann kommen wir
erst also die hatten auch richtig
existenzächte und viele Ostdeutsche
haben sich eben auch vielleicht mehr
eine Konkurrenz gesehen in in Menschen
mit
Migrationshintergrund aber akzeptabel
ist es deshalb trotzdem nicht aber das
was sie gerade geschiltert haben das
habe ich auch in Köln gehört wo wir bei
türgestämmigen Familie gedreht haben
damals waren Arbeitsplätze
Ausbildungsplätze knapp und dann hatten
die wirklich Angst wenn sie mit gleichen
schulergebnissen kommen dass dann doch
wieder der deutschstämmige aus dem Osten
eher genommen wird als derjenige der mit
dem Migrationshintergrund kommt
Ausgrenzung Abwertung vorurteilskultur
und Herkunft als Makel ist das
vielleicht etwas das ostdeutsche und
Migranten
verbindet ich glaube es verbindet
Menschen immer die eine
minderheitenbiografie haben ähm ich
würde jetzt gar nicht das sozusagen
aufmachen sondern wenn man aus einer
ganz speziellen Herkunft vielleicht auch
mit besonderen Eltern im im Westen
kommen kann einem das auch passieren
dass man ausgegrenzt wird es gibt eine
gewisse Tendenz die sozusagen den
durchschnittlichen Lebenslauf für das
gegebene zu halten und ich habe immer
dafür geplediert dass unsere Stärke ja
eigentlich die Vielfalt ist und wenn wir
das immer weiter eingrenzen was ist noch
normal
dann
ist man sehr schnell dabei dass man viel
zu viele Menschen aus aus grenzt und es
gibt vielleicht eine gewisse Tendenz im
Augenblick alles zu vereinheitlichen und
damit auch zu verkürzen und deshalb
plediere ich immer für Vielfalt ja man
muss halt differenzieren aber das ist
sehr anstrengend man muss ja dann sein
gut aber das ist ja das Wesen das ist ja
das Wesen unserer Demokratie und auch
Europas ähm ich habe im Zusammenhang mit
unserer ersten Ratspräsidentschaft 2007
mal Rede im Europäischen Parlament
gehalten und Karl Schack den
tschechischen
Schriftsteller zitiert der gesagt hat
der Schöpfer Europas hat es klein
gemacht und dann noch in winzige Teile
geteilt damit sich unsere Herzen an der
Vielfalt erfreuen und die Vielfalt ist
ja eigentlich das schöne dass die
Menschen nicht gleich geboren werden
sondern unterschiedlich geboren werden
und das bedeutet natürlich auch dass ich
mich in die Schuhe des anderen hinein
verersetzen muss aus dem blickfinkel
gucken muss aber das ist ja auch eine
Bereicherung sie haben mal gesagt als
sie halt Kanzlerin waren ich bin die
Bundeskanzlerin aller deutschen das
schließt alle die hier dauerhaft leben
mit ein jetzt bezogen auf die deutsche
Einheit Frau Merkel braucht Deutschland
eine neue Erzählung die zugewanderte die
eben dauerhaft hier leben mit
einschließt ja selbstverständlich es
braucht diese erzählungs braucht es
eigentlich schon immer aber da wir ja
jetzt auch in den letzten Jahren sehr
viele Menschen
ähm haben die dauerhaft in unserem Land
leben und noch nicht immer hier gelebt
haben ist das wieder eine neue Aufgabe
dass wir sie mit aufnehmen
ja Deutschland umfasst alle ich habe
darüber auch mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan sehr häufig
gesprochen wer ist verantwortlich z.B
für türkischstämmige Menschen die hier
zweite dritte Generation wohnen und ich
habe immer gesagt
pass auf dass deren Bundeskanzlerin bin
ich und das bedeutet nicht nur für
türkischstämmige den deutschen Staat und
seine Gesetze auch anzunehmen und zu
[Musik]
respektieren wir sind auf der dresner
Augustusbrücke hier wird das gastmah für
alle
gefeiert jetzt gibt es 33 Jahre die
deutsche Einheit und immer noch haben
die nicht zueinander gefunden so richtig
woran liegt das denn nicht mal die Ost
und westdeutschen haben alle bis jetzt
zueinander gefunden und sie fragen mich
wie ist das mit den
Ausländer wir sehen das hier in tresden
auch wenn man heute durch die Neustadt
geht ist es anders als vor 10 Jahren
viel bunter geworden und das ist
natürlich für viele Leute beängstigend
für ein Fest sind viele bereit zu kommen
besonders wenn es auch schmeckt aber
sonst wenn es um eine richtige
Diskussion geht wie läu bei uns sind die
Probleme dann sich die meisten sein wir
ehrlich wir haben noch viel vor
uns Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
und ostdeutsche beklagen eigentlich
häufig die gleichen Dinge und haben viel
mehr gemeinsam als ich vor meiner Reise
gedacht
hätte Zufriedenheit wird sich nicht so
schnell einstellen zu groß die
Unterschiede bei Vermögen und Biografien
zu gering die Mitsprache von
ostdeutschen und
zugewanderten was aber jeder erwarten
dar
Anerkennung
Gleichbehandlung und
Respekt